[Musique]
c'est le dernier atelier connu de
Jean-Paul Riopel en France il avait
acheté un garage qui était un garage
automobile il l'a acheté à l'époque pour
faire cet atelier puisque c'était énorme
et pour pouvoir stocker ses voitures ses
œuvres un peu tôt
a travaillé ici pendant plus d'une
vingtaine d'années et ce marchand d'art
a transformé le lieu en résidence tout
en essayant de conserver un peu de lame
du peintre voilà la pièce la fameuse
pièce en hommage à Jean-Paul il a entre
autres tapissé les murs de cette pièce
avec certains de ses décès son des
essais lithographiques ça n'a aucune
valeur commerciale mais ça a une valeur
bibliographique et donc j'ai décidé de
tapisser une pièce complète
c'est quand même un des maîtres de
l'abstraction
l'expressionniste abstrait il a fait
partie de l'avant-garde de l'École de
Paris ça mérite respect je respecte
l'homme je respecte tous les gens qui
sont passés ici parce que c'était un
lieu de vie également entre John
Mitchell les Giacometti toute une
génération d'artistes il venait déjeuner
picoler
la plupart des artistes que Jean-Paul
riopait la fréquenté en Europe sont
aujourd'hui disparus mais pas Roselyne
Granet
il payait toujours à boire à tout le
monde on allait beaucoup au bistrot
racontait beaucoup d'histoires très
drôles personne ne connaissait le Canada
autour de lui donc il pouvait raconter
ce qu'il voulait et c'était très amusant
toujours
Roselyne Granet a beaucoup côtoyé
Riopelle à partir de la fin des années
1950 il venait régulièrement à son
atelier de sculpture et à sa fonderie
adjacente il a d'ailleurs été
copropriétaire de cette fonderie pendant
quelques années c'était un chasseur
c'était aussi un chasseur de femmes ça
c'est sûr mais ça je peux après je peux
pas dire parce que ça m'est un peu égal
de mon fils
[Musique]
était très populaire en Europe et en
France en particulier où il s'est établi
au milieu du siècle dernier après son
engagement avec les automatismes au
Québec il s'est lié un temps avec les
surréalistes en France et sa production
a connu un grand essor ces toiles se
vendaient beaucoup et très cher il avait
des périodes où il peignaient
jour et nuit pendant quelques jours
pendant un certain temps et puis ensuite
il pouvait rester plusieurs années sans
peindre et quand il baignaient pas il
est très malheureux il buvait beaucoup
il traînait et puis tout d'un coup la
peinture revenait et à ce moment-là il
était très heureux il ne buvait plus il
travaillait beaucoup
[Musique]
il m'apportait plus que moi je ne lui
apportais au point de vue de métier au
point de vue de l'art il connaissait
tout le monde il connaissait tout
il avait des marchands Canadiens qui lui
qui venait attendre à la porte de la
France l'atelier qui lui proposait des
paquets d'argent contre les tableaux ça
a été fou à ce moment-là et donc lui il
dépensait tout il invitait tout le monde
à manger
Roselyne le Granet est reconnu pour sa
capacité à capter le mouvement dans ses
oeuvres et son ami Jean-Paul Riopel a
été pour un temps un de ses modèles vous
avez un gros fauteuil en cuir qui était
installé là et à cette époque là
Jean-Paul avait des problèmes de genoux
et donc il venait et il s'asseyait dans
le fauteuil et un jour moi je trouvais
que la relation entre le personnage et
le fauteuil était très intéressant et
donc j'ai commencé à faire son portrait
dans le fauteuil et j'en ai fait une
vingtaine là des petits et puis
finalement j'ai fait le grand où il
dormait il dormait dans le fauteuil
[Musique]
l'artiste française aujourd'hui
âgé de 87 ans a aussi réalisé la
sculpture grandeur nature de l'artiste
qui domine la place Riopelle à Montréal
une oeuvre qu'elle a créée peut après sa
mort
dans son atelier de la banlieue
parisienne Roselyne Granet a créé une
galerie des proches qu'elle a perdu ceux
qu'elle appelle ses morts son mari
debout au centre séparant d'un côté et
les amis Dory Opel de l'autre
il avait quand même une très belle tête
il s'est un peu abîmé avec le temps
parce que c'est vrai que l'alcool était
quand même ravageur la vie
pas très bien
la tête de rester quand même très belle
aujourd'hui les traces de Jean-Paul
Riopel en France sont plutôt rares on
est peut-être en train de l'oublier
là-bas
le monde de l'art change tout le temps
[Musique]
si c'est intéressant c'est de faire un
panorama en montrant qu'à la fin il
devient punk il devient street artiste
moi j'aime beaucoup les dernières les
doigts tout ça j'aime beaucoup parce que
c'était un grand dessinateur et qu'à la
fin elle le dessin est très présent je
trouve ce qui manque à Riopel c'est une
grande rétrospective en Europe
Jean-Paul Riopel laisse derrière lui une
œuvre monumentale aujourd'hui disséminée
à travers le monde
[Musique]